[Música]
[Aplausos]
con qué herramientas están afrontando en
estos momentos la vida
seguramente muchos se quedaron en blanco
hoy estoy orgulloso de estar aquí frente
a ustedes como ese futbolista que entre
1800 jugadores formó parte en algún
momento de una categoría inferior de un
equipo de fútbol y logró ese sueño de
debutar en primera división del fútbol
mexicano
lo cual quiere decir que para que cuatro
compañeros más hayan logrado este mismo
sueño tan anhelado por todos esos
jugadores 10.000 jugadores se tuvieron
que quedar en el camino
y eso no me hace sentir ni más ni menos
que cualquiera que en algún punto de su
vida ya que veo jugar fútbol pero se
rompió la rodilla y pues ya mejor lo
dejo
todo comenzó me acuerdo bien entre los 8
y los 10 años cuando pasaba horas y
horas al lado de mi papá viendo fines de
semana enteros partido tras partido y me
acuerdo como si fuera ayer la emoción
que sentía cada que un jugador hacia un
gol o cada que un equipo que iba
perdiendo
lograba remontar los últimos minutos el
marcador
por esas mismas fechas el equipo local
de mi ciudad dorados de culiacán había
logrado el anhelado ascenso
dorados un equipo en el cual ha pasado
jugadores como por temor blanco
borghetti guardiola entrenador un
entrenador como lo es diego armando
maradona
recuerdo bien que fue el boom en la
ciudad ya que culiacán es una ciudad
100% beisbolera a cualquier niño ahí nos
llevan primero a jugar béisbol que
cualquier otro deporte
y esta es la evidencia del primer error
en mi vida
un pelotazo y un retiro a muy temprana
edad
entonces todas esas horas al lado de mi
papá en el televisor ahora se
trasladaron a un estadio de verdad
y recuerdo lo emocionante que era
asistir temprano al estadio ver las
estadísticas de los jugadores sus fotos
el correr cada vez que los jugadores
salían a calentar para evitarles a cada
uno de ellos que si por favor me podían
regalar su playera o que me firmen
cualquier parte que se pudiera
era tan emocionante ese momento junto a
todos esos días al lado de mi papá
viendo el fútbol que me llevaron a mí a
visualizar me siendo un futbolista de
verdad que empiece a generar emociones
dentro de mí qué
que me hacían vibrar cada quien
imaginaba a portar un uniforme de fútbol
o salir en la tele y representar a un
equipo y hacer goles para ayudar que ese
equipo gane
deseaba tanto que a mis papás les pedí
que por favor me cambiaran de deporte y
en vez de jugar béisbol me llevaron un
equipo de fútbol
también me llevaron al atrevimiento de
preguntarle a mi papá que si él
[Música]
me creía capaz que en algún momento
pudiera yo ser un futbolista profesional
y salía en la tele ese era mi mayor
sueño
y no sé si fue por buen padre o porque
simplemente no quiso romper mis
ilusiones a los 10 años
pero lo que me hizo sentir al escucharlo
decir que yo sin duda podía lograr ese
sueño fue lo que encendió mis ganas y
fue la motivación por volverme
futbolista cuando ni siquiera sabía que
había que hacer ni cuál era el camino
que había que tomar para hacerlo
llevo 10 años como futbolista
profesional hasta el día de hoy
ininterrumpidos así que preferiría tener
un balón de fútbol a un micrófono en
estos momentos o preferiría estar en un
estadio lleno jugando una final con
60.000 personas gritando y abusando y no
sentir ni la mitad de los nervios que he
sentido desde que me invitaron a estar
aquí
pero de eso se trata la vida
así lo veo yo el asumir retos para mí me
hace superar me nace exigirme y me hace
crecer tanto en lo profesional como en
lo personal
y es que hoy en día nuestra generación
está atravesando un problema muy grande
porque no es normal que 2 de cada 5
jóvenes
que salen de la universidad no
encuentren un trabajo no es normal que
el 41% de los
profesionistas menores de 30 años estén
desempleados
y porque les cuento todo esto de mi
historia y mi sueño es porque creo que
cada vez somos menos esas personas que
vamos tras ese sueño que tuvimos de
niños por muchas razones porque nos han
dicho que es una locura
o porque nos dicen que no somos capaces
y nosotros preferimos creerles a esas
personas que creer en nosotros mismos
o porque simplemente cuando fuimos y
tocamos la primer fuerte y nos
encontramos con uno
no tuvimos el valor suficiente para ir y
tocar las 10 2030 puertas que eran
necesarias hasta encontrar ese sí
y gran parte del problema creo yo está
en que soñamos mucho soñamos porque nos
han dicho que soñar es gratis
y es que no se requiere de mover ningún
dedo para imaginarte ser el mejor
arquitecto o el mejor deportista no se
requiere leerte ningún libro para
imaginarte ser la mejor abogada o la
mejor licenciada
porque realmente esos sueños cuantos se
hacen realidad de la noche a la mañana
de estar soñando
imaginarte ser la mejor o el mejor en lo
que hace es despertar y hacerlo ninguno
y es que ahí está el problema que lo que
es gratis lo hacemos muy fácil lo
hacemos muy bien no se nos complica pero
cuando sabemos el precio que conlleva
hacer realidad esos sueños es cuando
muchos no se atreven a cumplirlo
es por eso que los últimos 20 años de mi
vida el fútbol ha sido para mí una
escuela de vida
y es que gracias al fútbol he encontrado
herramientas como la disciplina
una actitud correcta
y amor por lo que hago
pero que es disciplina
para ustedes
seguro cada uno tendrá su propia
definición
para el que no sepa disciplina es el
conjunto de reglas y normas cuyo
cumplimiento de manera constante
conducen a cierto resultado
para mí la disciplina es el conjunto de
acciones con las cuales yo creo
rotundamente que me llevarán a marcar
una diferencia en un deporte en el que
todos los días vivo en competencia
directa
acciones como cuidar mi alimentación
como dormir bien que sé que me llevarán
a tener un mejor rendimiento
invertir horas extra en trabajar mis
debilidades en potencializar mis
cualidades
el invertir le tiempo y energía a mi
cuidado tanto físico como mental que en
un deporte es muy importante
gracias a estas acciones la disciplina
me llevo
a cumplir ese sueño que todo jugador
tiene en algún momento y es que cuando
escuchó gritar mi nombre
edu
y pararme frente a una línea en la cual
yo sé que al atravesar la voy a cumplir
ese sueño que tuve a los 10 años al lado
de mi papá
cuando llamar de inmediato al camiseta 7
eduardo pérez el cambio es inminente que
le estará diciendo que le estaba
diciendo warrior el chelís a este joven
seguramente queda el juego en el empate
depende de cuatro resultados
necesita que no ganen los de abajo que
no gane querétaro que juega contra
jaguares de entrada cambio presentado
por x de repro de cualquier esta
tecnología extrema para tu motor se van
yo bajo el lesionado ingrese eduardo
pérez pero además santos tendría que ver
qué pasa ese sueño de debutar en primera
división y salir en la tele
la realidad es que no recuerdo aún lo
que el chelís me dijo en ese instante
entre los nervios el hueso y la emoción
que sentía pero lo único que recuerdo es
agarrar el teléfono y marcarle a mi papá
y decirle me viste en la tele lo
logramos es ha ido cuando le doy valor a
este a esta herramienta que es la
disciplina para cumplir los objetivos en
la vida
y ante una dificultad cuantos de ustedes
se han rendido
seguramente muchos
en abril del 2018
viví el mejor momento y por lo que todo
deportista y equipo de fútbol trabajar
todos los días ser campeón seré el
número uno en su disciplina
y es que todavía recuerdo ese momento en
el estadio lleno con 60.000 aficionados
gritándonos y abusando nos y haber
obtenido ese título compartirlo con mis
compañeros todo el esfuerzo recordado de
todo el torneo momentos difíciles y
momentos muy alegres resumidos en
levantar una copa
y en ese momento de alegría la verdad es
que no me imaginé que dos meses después
iba a estar atravesando por el peor
momento en mi carrera
esa lesión de rodilla
que ha retirado muchos futbolistas
desgraciadamente
pero ese puño para mí significó el
asumir la actitud correcta ante la
situación que estaba presentándome
y que esa actitud correcta para mí es no
rendirme
es hacer esas acciones con las cuales yo
creo que voy a marcar la diferencia para
recuperarme es asimilar una noticia tan
dura cuando en un diagnóstico te dicen
que 8 meses no voy a poder estar con mis
compañeros en un terreno de juego
es la incertidumbre si voy a poder
regresar bien a lo que tanto amo a lo
que tantos tiempo y dinero y energía le
invertido
pero fue con esa actitud de no rendirme
con esa actitud correcta con la que
asumí las cosas
con esas disciplinas esas acciones
que me llevaron a visualizar me que una
vez que yo regrese todo habrá valido la
pena que cuando yo regrese a las canchas
voy a regresar más fuerte más rápido voy
a saltar más alto y voy a hacer lo que
tanto me gusta y hacerlo bien
y el primer partido después de esos
ocho meses me encuentro con esta acción
que resume todo lo vivido
y
afirmaron en creció el tráfico genera
buena posibilidad seleccionar el
atacante estilo y adentro
[Música]
wow un festejo el cual no solo fue mío
sino fue de toda esa gente que me
acompañó
[Aplausos]
es una emoción indescriptible la verdad
es ese puño el cual yo el día al primer
día en el hospital levanté para
asimilarlo con la actitud saber que la
disciplina me iba a poner en el lugar
que debía y como lo mencioné y es un
festejo el cual es de mi familia de mis
amigos de los fisioterapeutas que me
acompañaron durante el proceso que pude
volver y hasta la fecha seguir viviendo
este sueño
y ahora una pregunta seria
desde que emociones están vibrando en
estos momentos
y tranquilos no le duele el horóscopo
para mí el amor lo describe muy bien yo
dispensa en su libro deja de ser tú
donde vemos como emociones
como la inseguridad la culpa la
vergüenza
nos llevan a vibrar muy bajo nos llevan
a sentirnos físicamente densos
pesados son esos momentos en los cuales
en la vida sentimos que no avanzamos y
que nos salimos del hoyo en el que
creemos estar
pero escribe muy bien que cuando le
ponemos amor y más amor a las cosas que
hacemos
es cuando vibramos y es cuando nos
sentimos plenos en la vida y todo nos
sale bien
para mí el amor bueno además de ser
futbolista y representar a todos esos
aficionados que compran un boleto cada
15 días poder apoyar no sólo la nueva
playera del equipo
también como deportista considero que
llevo una responsabilidad ante la
sociedad
ante esos niños y niñas o jóvenes que
hoy tienen ese sueño que yo tuve en su
momento porque además de amar lo que
hago me apasiona poder compartirlo con
con todos los demás y es que poder ser
un ejemplo para quien no encontrado esa
pasión en su vida a través de mi trabajo
es algo que me apasiona y es algo que me
llama a hacerlo
hace dos años en ese mismo instante mi
peor carrera me encontré con un evento
text
en el cual justo publique que los sueños
se trabajan que fue una gran experiencia
ese día
y que esa vez estuve como espectador y
más adelante estaré con conferencistas
yo estoy aquí frente a ustedes con todo
el amor con toda la pasión para
compartir mi historia
y para decirles que herramientas como la
disciplina constante
con una actitud correcta
y haciendo con amor todo lo que
lo que hacemos
me he dado cuenta que la mejor escuela
que he tenido es el fútbol
pero esas son mis materias
y estoy seguro que me quedan muchas por
cursar
cuáles son las suyas
gracias
[Aplausos]